[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
are you aware that he texted his friend
that he talked to his dad about having a
mental breakdown and that he texted his
friend that his dad said suck it up new
details revealed about the relationship
between the accused oxford high school
shooter and his parents and we hear from
the defendant for the first time in the
movie theater murder trial i was scared
this guy was completely out of control
didn't seem to be acting rational plus
the deadly rust shooting we hear from
the family of victim helena hutchins for
the first time are we really supposed to
feel bad about you mr baldwin but first
the death of brianna taylor he said that
she was the one that shot at us
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
and welcome everybody to long crime
daily i'm brian ross in for brian
buckmeyer who's in kentucky covering the
trial of former police officer brett
hankinson and with me here in new york
is co-host terry austin and we begin
with a closer look now at the days
following the shooting death of brianna
taylor on thursday jurors were shown the
recorded police interview of defendant
brett hankinson
hankinson is not charged in the killing
of brianna taylor but instead faces
charges of wanton endangerment for
firing shots through taylor's apartment
into a unit behind hers in march 2020
three officers executed a no knock
warrant to taylor's apartment her
boyfriend believing the officers were
intruders fired shots at them the
officers fired back and taylor was
killed in that crossfire former
louisville police officer john mattingly
who assisted higginson in the raid was
also shot on tuesday jurors were shown
video of hankinson's police interview
recorded just 12 days after the shooting
i didn't know if john was down and they
couldn't get his body out or he was
that all i could hear was the firing i
saw the flashes i thought they were just
being executed because i knew they were
helping john because john said i'm hit
i'm down
and
get the gunfire intensified so i always
open the spending compression at the
time they were either all getting
sprayed with bullets or
as they were trying to move him out of
that breezeway he was shooting at us
through the wall or them because i now
had a shot or i now had my only option
was to turn fire and i did that
to the muzzle flashes and i want to be
specific about this i had already seen
where the threat was i saw where he was
positioned in the hallway so when i made
that corner and i heard and saw what i
just described the muzzle flashes
i returned fire
at the angle
that i believed him to still be shooting
from because i could still see those
muzzle flashes in here and the fire
increased
like almost like a almost like an
automatic type weapon or what in my mind
was
was an automatic weapon
law and crime daily host brian buckmeyer
joins us now live in louisville kentucky
and brian day two marked even more
commotion in the courtroom
absolutely brian for the second day in a
row
brianna taylor's family were asked to
leave the courtroom for wearing shirts
and jackets depicting taylor's photo on
thursday brianna taylor's mother tamika
palmer was asked to leave for wearing
this jacket that reads brianna taylor
saying her name she was escorted out of
the courthouse entirely yesterday
taylor's sister janaya palmer was asked
to leave for wearing a shirt that said
quote arrest the cops who killed brianna
taylor taylor's family members tell me
this
tell me how it all went down they were
asked to step out of the court they
waited outside the sheriff somewhat
poked the picture of taylor on her chest
that being tamika palmer's chest saying
that this was the issue but didn't
really give a full explanation more
sheriffs came up to the courtroom and
escorted palmer her daughter and her
friend outside of the building they told
me they'll be back tomorrow tomorrow the
jury's expected to be at the home of
briana taylor law and crime daily will
be there for gavin to gavel coverage not
only inside the court but also outside
and joining us now is co-host terry
austin and legal analyst kirk nermey
kirk hankinson isn't charged with
brianna taylor's death but he is the
only officer involved in the raid who
faces criminal charges do you think
we'll ever expect to see the other two
officers charged in any way
well you know brian the evidence in this
case doesn't really advance that
possibility we heard that the police
knocked instead of having a no knock
warrant and we heard that they were
fired upon and they returned fire so
that in and of itself does not enhance
that possibility but of course the
evidence in this case is far from
complete and one of the key aspects of
answering your question i think might be
the testimony of mr hankinson himself
because
we don't know what he's going to say and
that could alter things that could alter
the possibility of that and kind of the
same way we saw mr durst take the stand
in california and wind up being charged
in new york so that possibility always
exists but it's just going to depend on
what mr hankinson has to stay should he
take the stand right and terry austin
during brett heckinson's interview
following the shooting he became
emotional at one point what's the impact
you think from that on the jury
oh i think it's going to have a
significant impact on that jury it was
powerful testimony it was conducted
right after the incident so his memory
was fresh he got emotional when they
started talking about his partner
officer mattingly who actually was
injured during the incident and so i
think that they're going to look at that
and recognize he is feeling something
for mattingly interestingly enough the
judge called him to a sidebar told the
defense look move on this is not about
mattingly it's about hankinson and go to
the next issue so they did
and brian what's your take on the police
interrogation video shown to jurors
hankinson mentioned taylor's boyfriend
kenneth walker had an ar-15 rifle
yeah that was pretty peculiar we were
seeing a lot of the jurors really
focused on the edge of their seat
a number of them are writing notes so
they're definitely paying attention that
point about the ar-15 came up through
cross-examination redirect and re-cross
in the sense that no long rifle no uh
ar-15 was found at the location and no
shell casing for an ar-15 or a type of
gun like that was there so while brett
hankinson took the steps that may have
been proper for that type of gun at a
location or someone shooting it it
appears that his observation of what
occurred was completely false it's going
to be interesting to see how either side
the prosecution or the defense argues
that but right now it seems like the
prosecution has a bit of the upper leg
on that issue all right thank you brian
buckmeyer in louisville for us tonight
still ahead on long crime daily eight
years after a deadly movie theater
shooting accused murderer curtis reeves
takes the stand in his own defense
but first the deadly rush shooting the
family of victim helena hutchins speaks
out and points the finger at alan
baldwin
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live one
crime network with youtube tv for all of
your daily live trial coverage legal
news expert analysis and original true
crime programs subscribe to youtube tv
today and then locate law and crime in
the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
and welcome back for the first time
we're hearing from the husband of
cinematographer helena hutchins who was
shot and killed by alec baldwin on a
movie set last year law and crimes
anjanet levy is here with what matt
hudgins is saying about the death of his
wife and jeanette
brian matt hutchins is suing alec
baldwin and others for the death of his
wife helena that wrongful death lawsuit
claims that at least 15 industry
standards were violated that day when
alec baldwin shot and killed helena
hutchins and it was all happening on the
set of that movie rust hutchins spoke
for the first time publicly in an
interview with the today show on nbc an
animation of a recreation of that
shooting was released by hutchinson's
lawyer showing what they believe
happened and how this whole thing
transpired baldwin has said he was told
the gun was safe after the assistant
director handed it to him but baldwin
did not check the weapon himself matt
hutchins talked about losing his wife
safety concerns on the set and alec
baldwin's claim that he didn't pull the
trigger and is not at fault for what
happened
i feel that that that
someone is responsible
for what happened and i can't say who
that is but i know it's not me but
watching him i just felt so angry
just so angry to see him talk about her
death so publicly
in such a detailed way
and then
to not accept any responsibility
after having just described killing her
he said essentially he felt grief but no
guilt
almost sounds like he was the victim
after matt hutchins filed that wrongful
death lawsuit against alec baldwin and
many others involved in this film
baldwin's attorney issued a lengthy
statement saying that actors should be
able to rely on armorers and assistant
directors to ensure that the weapons on
the set are safe that armorer and
assistant director are also named in the
lawsuit brian thanks anjanet kurt normie
baldwin has said he did not pull the
trigger of the gun and that he as you
heard is not responsible if all of that
was true would he still be found liable
for the shooting
well we talk about civil liability
certainly brian but if you're asking
specifically about criminal liability i
still think there's a possibility
because we have negligence and reckless
standards so did he do anything that was
negligent or reckless with the gun when
he was
doing this quick draw procedure that
that led to mitch's hutchinson's death
so that's what's going to have to be
determined but there's so many layers of
this that i think it's going to be hard
to prosecute because he could he rely
was it reasonable for him to rely on the
fact that there wasn't live ammo all
questions like that have to be answered
before i think any prosecuting agency
could go forward and seriously charge mr
baldwin right and terry austin we've
seen baldwin and now hutchins speak to
the press the battle over the media
narrative is on but that's only one
thing how does that weigh on what
happens ultimately in court
generally it is not a good idea brian to
speak to the press and that's whether
you have a pending civil litigation like
we have here with the wrongful death or
whether you have a potential criminal
liability here you could say something
in the press where you're making an
admission or you misstate a fact and it
will be held against you and here we saw
baldwin denied responsibility and that
got the family that got mad hutchins
upset and so now as far as the civil
case is concerned if in fact they want
it to settle it will be more difficult
and it will not be amicable and frankly
i don't think either one of them should
be in the press trying to case
and angenette what is the status of the
criminal investigation into helena
hutton's death
well brian the santa fe county sheriff's
office is investigating the shooting to
determine exactly what happened how that
live ammunition ammunition actually made
it onto the set because we've heard so
many times that live ammo shouldn't be
anywhere near a movie set so the
investigation is well underway there was
a search warrant executed on alec
baldwin's phone and we know that that
material has been turned over to the
sheriff's office so we're waiting to see
what recommendations the sheriff's
office makes to the district attorney
because they will eventually turn that
investigation over to the d.a who will
make the final decision on whether any
charges will be pursued
thanks anjanet coming up on law and
crime daily the parents of the accused
oxford high school shooter ethan ethan
crumbly are back in court
plus accused murderer curtis reeves
takes the stand in his own defense hear
the defendant's testimony ahead on law
and crime daily
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily the
defense rests its case in the trial of
former police captain curtis reeves and
all eyes were on the witness stand
thursday as he testified in his own
behalf for allegedly shooting and
killing a fellow moviegoer in a theater
eight years ago
reeves began his testimony talking about
his background including military
experience his former training as a
tampa police recruit and working with
weapons this went on for nearly an hour
and a half reeves attorney then moved on
to ask about the day of the shooting
january 13 2014 reeves faces
second-degree murder charges for the
shooting death of chad olson after
apparently getting frustrated with him
being on his cell phone during the movie
previews a few witnesses have testified
olson through popcorn at reeves reeve
says olson threw a cell phone at him and
was coming at him over the row of seats
in front of him that's when he says he
had no alternative so he pulled out his
gun and shot olson he says in
self-defense
i was scared
this guy was completely out of control
didn't seem to be acting rational
i was so scared until i was not sure
exactly where he was but i knew he was
attacking me
well kirk newman do you think grief's
taking the stand helped him or hurt him
well you know i think it could only hurt
him at that point i knew that he was the
kind of guy that had the ego that he
would want to take the stand and i know
he's been probably sitting in his home
on house arrest for eight years waiting
for this moment but given all the
defense case we saw before brian we saw
a lot of experts talk about what he went
through we saw reenactments we saw all
kinds of we heard his interview tape
plate so there was really no reason for
him to take the stand and it really i
think only could hurt him when on
cross-examination and one of the things
i was watching when i was watching this
cross-examination is his body language
he came across angry but he also came
across pretty ambulatory you know the
the prosecutor i think did something
smart he had him get up move around to
show that this was not the completely
feeble old man especially when we go
back eight years ago that the medical
experts and he was claiming himself to
be right terry reeves spent a
significant amount of his time
discussing his career as a police
officer what do you think was the
defense strategy in going into his law
enforcement background
well i think the defense was trying to
show look this man is old he's got
physical conditions that really make him
more vulnerable and the fact that he was
a police officer means he knows about
dangers he knows that people carry
weapons he knows that they could use
their fist and this is why
we have this situation where he
overreacted and he's shot now they're
trying to say it wasn't an overreaction
but clearly i agree with kirk this is an
overreaction and i think the jury sees
that all right terry and kirk thank you
very much now a program note coming up
this week i'm brian ross investigates
baseball blues the sport has been rocked
by a new drug scandal all coming to
light now following the overdose death
of a los angeles angel pitcher tyler
skaggs and testimony in court about
widespread use of drugs among other
players
unfortunately what it did
at a time when nobody's playing baseball
or planning to play baseball is it
reignited memories of the cocaine
scandals of the 70s or the pittsburgh
pirates and it pointed up exactly what
is the matter with major league baseball
right now they're always behind in
fixing problems that they should have
addressed beforehand
that's coming up this week on brian ross
investigates on the long crime trial
network when we come back we head to
michigan for day two of jennifer and
james crumbly's preliminary hearing
the newest details revealed by
prosecutors about the days leading up to
the deadly oxford high school shooting
and welcome back a big development in
minneapolis thursday night all three
ex-officers were found guilty in federal
court in connection to the death of
george floyd two towel thomas lane and
jay alexander king were found guilty of
violating george floyd's rights in may
of 2020. federal jurors deliberated for
about 13 hours our legal analysts will
dig deeper into that conviction on the
next episode of law and crime daily
and just days after the accused oxford
high school shooter appears in court
himself a preliminary hearing for his
parents back in session
jennifer and james crumley are charged
with four counts of involuntary
manslaughter following the shooting
spree at oxford high school last
november prosecutors say their son 15
year old ethan crumley opened fire at
the school killing four students and
injuring others prosecutors say parents
jennifer and james crumley gifted their
son the weapon that was used in the
school shooting and ignored the multiple
warning signs from the school including
disturbing drawings made by ethan and
reports that he kept a bird's head in a
jar on thursday prosecutors described
how both parents acted when ethan told
them he suffered a mental breakdown they
verified the oxford high school
counselor was not aware of these
conversations
are you aware that ethan had texted his
mom about seeing demons yeah were you
aware that he texted his mom about
things flying off shelves no were you
aware that he had asked several times to
see a therapist
were you aware that he thought he was
having a mental breakdown at some point
were you aware that ethan had tested his
friend that um
he talked to his mom about getting help
and she laughed at him
objection
i don't believe that because i don't
believe that text has come in as
evidence
there is not
that the fact that mom laughed at him
about therapy is is not a part of the
evidence in this case were you aware
that he texted his friend that he talked
to his dad about having a mental
breakdown and that he texted his friend
that his dad said suck it up
no
fifteen-year-old ethan crumbly faces
charges of terrorism and first-degree
murder a michigan judge has until next
week to decide whether ethan will be
relocated to a children's village or
stay put in the oakland county jail for
adults
so kirk the judge has now bound over the
parents for trial after that hearing the
crumblies were bound over does that
change the preliminary hearing and gives
a kind of a preview of what we're going
to see at the trial
you're right brian it is a great preview
but keep in mind when this case gets in
front of a jury that jury might very we
made well
made up of parents who probably aren't
would admit they're not perfect parents
themselves so when the state moves
forward with this case they're going to
have to show extreme tangible signs that
were neglected by both jennifer and
james crumley in order to make their
case
in order to prove that this was so
outrageous that this legal
leap that the state wants to take in
this novel charge is one that they
should find him guilty for and that's
going to require a lot of tangible
evidence but like as you said going
ignoring all that tangible evidence and
then putting a weapon
capable of killing individuals in his
hand despite all those signs that will
earn him a conviction and terry this
case is making legal news in part
because of the novel aspect of the
parents being charged with a crime some
think that's what should happen more
often in these cases
well i think you have people on both
sides of that issue brian people who
think that the parents should be
responsible but only in situations that
are so extreme like this case i think
the prosecution is absolutely right to
bring four counts of involuntary
manslaughter against the crumblies
because here you can see that there is
some criminal negligence here there's no
question they bought the gun they knew
about the mental illness they failed to
lock up the gun they did nothing when
they heard about the trouble the child
was having so i think this case is the
case to do that all right terry and kirk
thank you so much for being here thank
you all for joining us here on law and
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you